Hello world. It's Saroj and it's
time to upgrade the entire Internet.
I'm going to explain how the
interplanetary file system or IPFS works.
We'll also use it to build a simple video
streaming web app onwards towards the
permanent wet. The web is the
backbone of our civilization.
So much of our economy,
our mission critical systems,
our most basic communication
channels depend on it to function.
The Orchestra of apps that give us such
amazing capabilities today are only
possible because we built the necessary
infrastructure to support them.
What we call the web is just
a collection of protocols.
These are sets of rules,
ideas on how to best transmit data that
have won over the hearts of developers
and then made standard by browser
adoption and tool dependency.
Anyone can write a protocol
and the existing ones were
written by people aiming
to solve small problems for themselves
and in the process ended up being adopted
by everybody else because
they worked really well.
There's one protocol in particular,
however that is in need of a serious
upgrade http developed by Tim Berners Lee.
We
use http to access most of the web.
It delivers virtually all file types and
is considered a client server protocol.
A client you on your laptop
with the browser for example,
can send the request message to a server,
say amazon.com and the server will then
return a response message like a home
page.
It's worked well enough,
but we're starting to see
some real problems with http.
The first problem is bandwidth.
More and more of the world is coming
online fast and that means more people are
demanding more data.
Websites crash all the time because too
many people are trying to access them at
the same time.
Imagine this scenario.
Let's say I'm sitting in a classroom with
some other students were studying sex
robots. I want to share a useful picture
with them so I upload it to Facebook.
Then give them all the link
so they can fetch the image.
Assuming there are say eight links and
the total bandwidth required from my
upload is eight megabytes.
Then when 30 students request that image,
now that's 240 megabytes
of bandwidth usage.
If I uploaded a video and that
took 200 megs of bandwidth,
when all the other people watch it,
it'll take 48 gigs of bandwidth.
This is a horribly inefficient routing
scheme since they are so physically close
to me and it's getting to the point where
providing this amount of bandwidth is
no longer profitable for companies.
If we look at how much bandwidth has
improved over the past few years,
it's not very significant.
Compare that to how fast our storage
space is decreasing in cost and it's clear
that we are fast saturating these
pipes so the web will start to feel,
which leads to the second problem.
Latency.
Unfortunately we can't get around
the speed of light. It's a constant.
Could we just do an ICO? No. What?
So the only way to make data transfer
faster is to move the data closer to you,
which is why some cloud services
offer storage locations by region.
Still if I need a file and it just so
happens to be on a device one meter away
from me having my device make a request
through the backbone of the web to some
nearby city isn't nearly as fast as just
pulling it from that device directly.
The third problem is resiliency
in terms of connectivity.
If your ISP has an outage and your towns
connection to the global Internet goes
down,
you're out of luck.
There's nothing you can do about
that in terms of data permanence,
if Wikipedia was hacked
and all its data deleted,
we'd lose that knowledge forever.
It'd be akin to book burning Dwin.
Only a few copies of certain
books were available,
but it doesn't even have to
be that drastic an event.
Does this error look familiar to you?
You've likely seen a four oh four before,
which signifies that some content
has been deleted or moved.
Http links get broken all the time.
It's like mini book burning all the time.
If data isn't manually copied by someone,
that data is gone forever.
The last problem is centralization
because data has become so centralized.
Abuse services own most of our data and
we have no say in how that data is used.
This is unimaginable power.
The services can manipulate large swaths
of the populist with a few clicks and
access to them can be easily blocked by
governments and other oppressive forces
like what happened during the Arab spring
or during the pro democracy protests
in Hong Kong in 2014 we have
got to upgrade the internet.
It's too important not to.
IPFS was designed to help fix these
problems and help us move towards the
permanent web,
uh,
web where links never die and
no entity controls your data.
While the http web is Ip addressed,
the IPFS web is content addressed.
When requesting data
from a content address,
you'll receive it faster since it'll
route from whoever owns a copy of that
content address closest to you.
This helps make bandwidth
usage much more efficient.
When you upload a file to Ipfs,
you get back it's immutable Hash.
Each file in the network is identified
by its content. Using this hash.
The Hash is cryptographically
guaranteed to represent only that file.
Anyone can provide storage for IPFS data.
The storage providers are incentivized
with a crypto token and data is
replicated and chunked across all of
them by the network to maintain data
permanence.
To achieve this IPFS combines several
great ideas from computer science in the
past few years.
First to store data,
it uses a distributed hash table similar
to one propose at MIT called cord.
A DHT is a dictionary like interface to
data that is stored on nodes that are
distributed across the network.
The node that gets to store a particular
key is found by hashing that key,
so in effect, the Hash table buckets
are now independent nodes. In a network.
Data is exchanged between these nodes
using a mechanism called bits swamp.
Inspired by the popular
bittorrent torrent protocol,
the de facto way to transfer
large datasets across the web.
A user can discover nearby peers to share
data with. Then when requesting a file,
they can download many small bits of it
for many different peers all at once.
This format compensates
for bottleneck points,
which makes it much faster
than downloading a large
file from a single source to
give structure to the DHT and let users
find the data they need when they need
it.
IPFS uses a data structure called a Merkle
Dag inspired by the gift protocol get
uses a Merkle Dag to enable distributed
version control for source code and IPFS
uses it to give structure to the entire
network. It's simple and flexible.
We can conceptualize it as a series of
nodes connected together in the form of a
directed a cyclic graph.
It can look like a singly
linked list or a tree,
so whenever data is added to the Dht,
the system generates a public private key
pair and the user gets both. All right.
Let's get our hands dirty with IPFS.
We'll first install the
IPFS client on our machines.
There's a tar ball available for Mac and
Linux and an exe for installation for
windows.
Once I downloaded it,
I can untarnished and move the IPFS
binary to somewhere in my executable so I
can just run it directly from
terminal like so it's installed.
We can now initialize IPFS from
terminal and it will create our node,
generate an identity for us and allow
us to read files on the network.
If I read an address,
I can see the text I just
retrieved in terminal to go online.
We'll run the demon in another terminal.
We can now discover our peers in the
network by their peer identities.
We can read files directly from these
peers and there's even a fancy web console
for us to be able to see where
all the peers are in the world.
We can use this Ui to manage our instance.
Let's say we want to upload
a video that we have locally.
We can use the IPFS add command to add
that video to the network and use the
resulting hash we get as his identity.
Then in terminal,
we can view it directly or we can watch
it via a local gateway. In the browser.
Let's say we have a simple static web
app that lets users upload video and view
it.
It's just a simple html webpage.
With some assets we can add the whole
directory containing our web app to IPFS
directly. The very last hash next to
the folder name is the one we want.
It's the highest level hash of
the Merkle Dag we've just created.
We could create a simple DNS text
record and that view our site locally
or@theonlinehdptoipfsgatewayatipfs.io
it's called interplanetary because if and
when we do become an
interplanetary species,
it's much more efficient to use a web
that finds the data you need that's
closest to you,
not light years away.
The three closing points are the http
web is a few decades old now and has
become slow impermanent and centralized.
IPFS is a newer protocol that aims to
create a permanent web or links our
content not IP addressed and it uses a
distributed hash tables to store data,
a Merkle,
Dak to give it structure and a bit
torrent like data exchange mechanism to
maximize bandwidth. Last week, coding
challenge winner is two showers.
Tony Open mind needed to be
able to compute operations
on a tensor of arbitrary
type, so to shard demonstrated how to do
this programmatically. Such an epic PR,
great job, and the runner
up it's row hot, so walked.
Who implemented some much needed and
awesome styling updates to open minds
documentation.
This week's coding challenge is to
create your own simple web app using IPFS
post who get help.
Link in the comments because
I'm announcing the top
two entries next Friday.
I really hope you liked this video and
if you did hit the subscribe button and
all your dreams will come true. For
now, I've got to make a crypto rap,
so thanks for watching.